everything in HTML is a node that
includes the document all HTML elements
the text in the elements HTML attributes
in comments these form a node tree all
nodes in the tree can be accessed by
JavaScript nodes can be created modified
or deleted in a node tree the top node
is called the root node so inside the
document we have the root element which
is HTML and then every node has exactly
one parent except the root this element
head node and the element body node each
have the HTML node as the root node in
the head in the body are children of the
HTML node a node can have any number of
children also siblings are nodes with
the same parent so the head element is a
sibling of the body element and this a
elma is a sibling of the h1 element and
both these elements have the body
element as their parent element so here
we're creating an element document that
create element and we're making it a
paragraph a paragraph tag element then
we have to add the text to the paragraph
so we're going to create a text node so
we have create text node here and it's
going to add this text into that node
and then we're going to append them
together so we have the paragraph
element that we created and then we
append child and then the node this is
the text that we created so the text
node we created is a child of the
paragraph node now we just have to add
the node we created to the document
we're going to set parent to equal
document get element by ID div 1 that's
this div 1 up here in the HTML and we're
going to do parent got a pinned child
para so we're going to add a new child
node to this parent so to this div 1
where we're adding a new child node
which is the node that we created up
here so let me run that and we'll see it
up in the HTML see now we just added up
of the world so high at the end here we
appended the child okay let's try
something new here I'm going to create
another paragraph para to document
actually element P that's the same thing
we had in this line up here but we're
going to add the text differently so one
way to create the text is the create
text node but you can also set the inner
HTML to be the new text so this is also
creating a new text node within the
paragraph just this line is taking the
place of these two lines and it does
basically the same thing so now we're
going to get another element on the page
the child node is document dot get
element by ID p1 we now have this node
up here from the HTML and we're going to
insert before before we did append child
which always puts the new node at the
end but you can also put in new nodes
before other nodes so instead of parent
dot append child we have parent dot
insert before and the first thing we're
going to pass in is what we're going to
insert and then which is pair two that's
this up here that we created and the
second thing we're going to pass through
is what we want it to be inserted before
so we have the p1 up here which is the
twinkle twinkle little star and we want
to insert like a diamond in the sky
before twinkle twinkle little star so
let's run that and see what happens
yep just like what I said it inserts it
before twinkle twinkle little star I'm
going to show you two more things in
this video replacing a child and
removing a child so these first two
lines are just creating another
paragraph element we have pair of three
and it's going to be a paragraph element
and we're going to put the text when the
Blazing Sun is gone and now we're gonna
get the parent node that's the div the
div one replace child and the first
thing we're going to pass in is what the
new element is that we're going to be
putting in the second thing we're going
to be passing in is what we want to be
replaced so remember child is this p1 up
here that's the twinkle twinkle
are but now we want to replace it with
this new line this new paragraph so
let's try that and it's replaced it
doesn't say twinkle twinkle little star
anymore it says when the Blazing Sun is
gone and then the last thing I wanna
show you is removing a child so you have
parent that's the div again that remove
child and we just pass in what we want
to remove we want to remove pair of
three which is what we just added so if
we run that it does not say when the
Blazing Sun is gone anymore we've
removed that child thanks for watching
my name is beau Carnes don't forget to
subscribe and remember use your code for
good